[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a japanese youth comedy
drama film called flying colors
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
sayaka kudo is in middle school but has
no friends she is socially anxious and
often bullied by her classmates she has
two younger siblings brother ryuta and
sister mayumi her father only focuses on
ryuta who he thinks will one day become
a baseball superstar the sisters are
often left alone with their mother who
takes great care of them all of sayaka's
classmates have a dream in life she
however wants to do nothing because of
her lack of ambition she is not good at
studies either one day sayaka gets hit
on the head with a ball in the
playground her mother is called by the
principal and told that they cannot
teach someone like sayaka in the school
the teachers think she is suffering from
some kind of mental illness and needs to
go to a special school sayaka's mother
begs them to give her daughter a second
chance but her words go to waste as the
principal dismisses her while returning
home sayocase's two schoolgirls walk
past them she comments that their
uniform is pretty and hence is admitted
to the same school sayaka is nervous on
her first day scared that the new
classmates will bully her like the old
ones but to her surprise everyone is
nice to her especially a group of three
girls who befriend her instantly they
make her fold her skirt to make it
shorter so it would look better they
also do her makeup and hair in the
washroom and welcome her to their group
as the girls grow up they transform into
gyaru a person who follows western
traditions typically dyes their hair
blonde and wears revealing clothes they
frequently dress up party drink and
smoke completely disregarding their
studies their homeroom teacher mr
nishimura scolds them every day and
believes that they will certainly not
get into college most days sayaka
returns home in the morning when her
father and brother are exercising
outside the house the relationship
between her and her father has become
non-existent with time he only talks to
her when he has to scold her while she
ignores him entirely her mother however
is always on her side and supports her
even though she doesn't understand her
lifestyle sayaka's life changes on the
first day of sophomore year that is when
mr nishimura discovers a hidden packet
of cigarettes in her school bag she is
immediately sent to the principal's
office to face the repercussions of her
actions her mother is called and briefed
about all of sayaka's shenanigans she
begs the principal to let her daughter
stay arguing that the school's job is to
teach its weakest students not profit
off the smartest ones on her repeated
request they agree to let sayaka off
with a month of suspension since sayaka
has all this time on her hands she dyes
her hair blonde her mother suggests she
try to get into a university she
genuinely believes that if sayaka tries
she can do it to prepare her for her
university entrance examination miss
kudo sends her to saiho kram school the
teacher tsubata is shocked to see
someone like sayaka interested in being
tutored by him he motivates her and
takes on the challenge to help her enter
kaio university it is considered one of
the most prestigious and difficult to
enter universities in japan which makes
sayaka laugh at the thought that someone
like her could be selected to check the
level of her academics tsubata makes her
take a test sayaka scores 0 out of 100
but the teacher is still impressed
because she answered all of the
questions when any other student would
have given up at that point after
evaluating her academics he declares
that her knowledge is comparable to a
grade four student hence he starts from
the beginning teaching her the syllabus
from middle school the next day sayaka
goes to a restaurant with her friends
but studies the entire time the girls
are shocked and happy at the same time
that she is working hard towards
something after studying in the cram
school for a week she scores 5 out of
100 for the first time tsubata is happy
about the result and urges her to work
even harder he is a great teacher to all
of his students he never makes them feel
dumb for not knowing something and does
his best to keep their spirits up
however with sayaka he struggles a lot
because she doesn't even know simple
things like north is always opposite to
south sayaka's father refuses to pay for
her cram class because it's too
expensive moreover he doesn't believe
that she can ever get into a university
anyway her mother on the other hand is
determined to work harder and pay for
sayaka's tuition one day while sayaka is
studying in the cram school a mother
drags her son raiji inside he is also a
gyaru like sayaka and is uninterested in
studying raiji's parents are lawyers and
want him to take the same profession but
he is only interested in playing video
games tsubata asks him if he knows what
revenge play is this piques raiji's
interest and he starts to study hard to
get into law school and teach his father
a lesson as days pass by sayaka makes
significant progress but subato wants to
accelerate it hence he finds an
interesting way to teach her he makes
her take off a layer of makeup for every
wrong answer he even promises to show
the students an embarrassing picture
from his childhood when sayaka scores
100 in middle school's english test
starting that day sayaka studies all the
time and eventually gets a perfect score
on the test as promised tsubata shows
them a picture from his childhood and
tells them how he was an average student
which is why he wants to help them
following that sayaka dyes her hair
black and continues going back to school
when mr nishimura finds out she is
aiming to go to a university he jokes
about dancing naked in the school's
playground if she succeeds sayaka
challenges him and is even more
motivated after the incident one day
sayaka and raiji are outside a
restaurant when they see subata meeting
mr nishimura it turns out that mr
nishimura is also funding the cram
classes and doesn't want tsubata to take
in weak students like sayaka he thinks
the class's reputation is more important
than the student's future tubata argues
that he has faith in sayaka and knows
that she will get into her desired
university seeing a father figure stand
up for her sayaka gets teary at home
miss kudo notices that her daughter has
grown into a better person since she has
started to go to cram classes the next
day she is called by tsubata to discuss
sayaka's progress he claims that sayaka
is the fastest learning student he has
had but since they do not have much time
before the university entrance
examination she needs to come to cram
class six days a week this will cost her
a lot of money but she pays the school
after taking a loan from her relatives
sayaka finds out about this from tsubata
and is saddened that she is causing her
mother so much trouble one day her
friends invite her to a restaurant
sayaka goes but is busy studying the
entire time the girls then take her to
the hot spring and claim that they will
only hang out again after sayaka's exams
because they know how hard she is
studying for it sayaka cries and thanks
them for being understanding a few
months later sayaka finally upgrades to
the high school syllabus book and has to
study how to write an essay tsubata
gives her several books and asks her to
watch a lot of news when the syllabus
gets tougher she has a hard time
focusing she even cuts her hair short to
show her resolve over the weeks she
studies so hard that she dozes off
during most of her classes at school one
day mr nishimura wakes her up by
grabbing her hair he calls her mother to
tell her that her daughter hasn't
improved since she was suspended but
miss kudo retaliates saying that sayaka
is not the girl she was a few months ago
the next day at cram class raiji comes
in with dark hair glasses and a
completely changed look on being asked
he says that sayaka inspired him to work
harder following that sayaka takes her
first mock entrance exam when the
results are published she is
disappointed to have gotten only 60 out
of 100 when the minimum score to get
into her desired university is 70.
tsubata thinks it is incredible because
only some months ago she would have
scored zero but sayaka is disappointed
that all the hard work is still not
enough she returns home to see her
father manhandling her brother ryuta for
saying that he doesn't want to play
baseball anymore ryuta snaps and pushes
his father away shouting that he never
wanted to play baseball in the first
place he storms off and doesn't return
home that night the following day sayaka
takes yet another mock exam but still
doesn't score enough the stress and
sleep deprivation catches up to her and
she loses motivation to study tsubata
tries to motivate her but his optimism
makes her even more furious she lashes
out at him and runs away from the cram
class she doesn't come out of her room
for the next two days
then one night ryuta returns home and
informs his father that he has left the
school's baseball team ever since mr
kudo had to give up on his dream of
being a baseball player he had dreamt of
making his son the greatest player of
all time seeing his dreams crash down
once again he hits ryuta asking him to
come back to his senses miss kudo gets
so frustrated that she breaks a
vehicle's window to stop her husband
when he is distracted ryuda takes the
opportunity to run away from home again
miss kudo tells them about a time ryuda
had an asthma attack the night before a
match because he was scared he would be
scolded if he didn't perform well she
belittles her husband for being such an
awful father to all of his children
later sayaka asks her mother to
accompany her on a field trip to kyo
university they visit the university
grounds the next day and are amazed by
it miss kudo wishes that her daughter
will have the same lifestyle as the busy
students walking down the hallways at
night sayaka goes to cram class and
meets subata she apologizes for being
rude and thanks him for being patient
with her she also promises to continue
the classes from the next day a week
later sayaka takes her third mock exam
but is too scared to look at the results
on coming back home she finds her father
burning all the baseball kits that he
bought for ryuta he has realized his
mistake and wants to be a better father
from now on he promises to support his
children with whatever they want to do
in life as the family shares an
emotional moment sayaka shows them the
recent mock exam results where she has
scored 65. her parents are prouder than
they have ever been cut to the day of
the entrance examination the roads are
blocked because of heavy snowfall and
the bus route is closed sayaka's father
offers to drive her which is surprising
because he has never been involved in
her life even in the slightest way on
their way he asks her to do her best and
not worry about the tuition fee because
he has it managed after dropping her off
he even cheers for his daughter for the
first time in his life sayaka does her
best on the test and returns home later
that day she goes to the cram class
declaring that it is her last day she
doesn't want to return to tell him the
results scared that she will disappoint
him she also makes subata sign her
dictionary so he would always be there
when she studies before leaving she
hands him a letter thanking him for
believing in her and making her who she
is today a few days later she checks the
result on the internet only to find that
she didn't pass she calls subata and
tells him about the result tsubata
doesn't give up and insists that they
can appeal for her answer sheet to be
rechecked under faculty policies sayaka
gives up and doesn't apply for it so
tsubata does it for her for the next few
days she goes out with her friends every
day trying to live her old lifestyle but
no matter what she does she cannot help
but feel disappointed then one day she
checks the results again and to her
surprise sees that she has gotten into
kyo university she immediately cycles to
the cram class and is out of breath when
she meets subata when she tells him that
she has been accepted the entire class
erupts into cheers both tsubata and
sayaka can't help but bawl their eyes
out in the last montage we see mr
nishimura naked on the school grounds
taking pictures with the girls as he had
promised
mr nishimura is going to jail sayaka
leaves for college after wishing her
parents farewell
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching